all right the new doctor who campaigned
has been revealed now I've been saying
for years that there are three things
that I am completely done with with our
gurus companions female young and from
the modern era now I know this one's
name bill so I'm feeling kind of hopeful
let's take a look and see what we got
out son of a [ __ ]
so bill being played by pearl Mackey I
know absolutely nothing about pearl
Mackey I've never seen her anything else
which is not saying much she hasn't done
much else so I'm not sure anyone has
much to go off of in terms of her past
performances but they gave us not only a
reveal of her look but also this sort of
couple minute little thing little sketch
almost up her with the doctor fleeing
from the dodge which is kind of a cool
way to reveal the character what do I
think mm-hmm this thing already had
several strikes against it just based
off of the fact that it fit the three
criteria that I've been saying for years
I'm done with when it comes to Doctor
Who companions and I know looking at her
outfit it's got kind of a retro vibe
almost an eighties feel so maybe she's
not strictly speaking from modern day
like maybe it maybe she's from the 80s
but as far as I'm concerned that's still
modern-day when I say I want something
up from mom and dad's I mean I want
someone from the far future from the far
past or from another planet I know what
the average age for Doctor Who fans is
these days but I remember the 80s pretty
clearly so that's still monitored in my
eye but if I try and set aside the fact
that she fits the template that I'm sick
of how was her performance bouncing off
the doctor it was okay
you know the dialogue in the banter it
wasn't unfunny but it just personally
for me it kind of rubbed me the wrong
way the way she's pointing out these
these things in a kind of a snarky
fashion this is a certain validity to it
cuz I mean they're the sorts of things
that someone brand-new to Doctor Who has
a show might try and point out it's kind
of interesting to have someone who's new
to the doctor within the show you know
meeting him deliver started to point out
these same kind of things but it went on
a bit too long they kept hitting the
same joke over and over again and I was
really done with it by about the second
go after she had her little thing of
saying well is there a Dalek with two
suckers because there were no more guns
and he's really ticked off like okay
cool yeah
and then but then we hit that same joke
a couple more times it was a little bit
of a relief for me that the doctor seems
kind of annoyed with her cuz I was kind
of annoyed with her so it was nice to
see that reflected but I think it's
really dangerous when you write a
character who intentionally grates on
your main characters because when you
write someone to be annoying by and
large they tend to just end up being
annoying even to the audience I mean the
saving grace is that while she's kind of
annoying she's not stupid these aren't
stupid questions she's asking she's
asking you at an inappropriate time but
again I kind of have the ice like that
and you look at say like look this is
basically a tiny bit of sketch comedy
featuring the doctor and the new
companion I need to try and look at it
through that filter and I come away
going I don't love this but I may come
to enjoy her because you know her
chemistry with Capaldi seemed fine I am
looking at her getting a feel for her
rhythm her delivery and it's fine
nothing about it is really grabbing me
and again I think a lot of that just has
to do with the fact that it fit that
template again if she had been you know
broken away from that template in some
fashion clearly been from a different
time period then someone older been a
man you know I I may have been fine with
all the rest of it with the dialog and
the vibes and the jokes and all of that
but from a starting place of this is
exactly what I've been saying I'm sick
of yeah I think I honestly got overly
critical of all the rest of it but of
course the good news is I will now have
all the time between this reveal and
when the show starts to get over that
and be able to deal with her more on her
own terms and I do think that there is
potential here because like I said
there's there's decent chemistry there's
decent banter
she seems playful but not without a
certain sense of urgency when it's
called for so I'm hopeful that I will
come to enjoy this character but based
solely off this little thing that we've
been given not a huge fan but hoping to
become one as time goes on is kind of
where I end up so if you're watching
this I'm going to assume that you have
seen the little reveal video of pearl
Mackie as bill what were your thoughts
on the whole thing whatever they were
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe follow me on Twitter I counsel
of geeks check out the Council of geeks
podcast
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
time this council is adjourned